I used to have this mean critical voice
in my head
but I committed to my recovery and I got
better
but sometimes I wonder if that voice is
what got me here
you ready
certainly am
hi I'm Sheila D Rubin let's move
you are a national television
personality now we're building a place
for women to be free of judgment
we should offer meditation yoga Pottery
lesbians yes
we're brainstorming there's no bad ideas
yes
we are on the precipice of something big
there's just one problem
[Music]
Kelly kilmartin she beat you to the
punch she's the most famous Fitness star
I'm better than you
oh no they're looking at you she's in my
head Fame against scrutiny
he's fake and a liar every time I think
you have hit bottom you've managed to
sink even lower
is really starting to scare me you don't
want to slow down now do you get so
close to the top I was hoping it
wouldn't come to this just kidding I was
dying for it to come to this it's got
time
this is more than just a business for me
this is my life I built this
I am Body by Sheila
[Music]
you're just hanging on by a threads just
waiting for that moment to snap I
thought you were on a healing Journey
we have put everything on the line what
if it doesn't work
I won't let it happen
isn't one of the steps in your recovery
Integrity recovery's a long road
[Music]
hey did you know that an Indian invented
potato chips you please just go it's
gonna go hug a guy inventing them yeah
it was half black half native don't
start talking to yourself it's true
you believe it's not
all right
the rest stops every time
it was so grounded where's there
I'm old enough to feel oh who's Beyond
enough that half the healing is often
found an opportunity to help others what
does that mean you're on trash Duty
maybe next time you'll think twice about
running away and not telling anybody why
am I here I didn't even go to California
it's called probably cause
knowledge bomb Oh God
glad to be home I don't think I could
leave this kind of gets a hold of you
huh so did I get my records records I'm
thinking about going to school
can you just tell me what to do you know
I can't do that besides you made it made
it where right where you're supposed to
be
I'm gonna die
we're Kindred Spirits I think we see
things other people can oh we shouldn't
people are either afraid of it or
they're jealous girl
I'm a spirit
your glass who's gonna adopt the people
up I don't know the one
I'm interested
[Music]
I try to be I know the noise you have
inside your head I know it's loud being
good or bad is a choice
there's time between us in and over
a lot of rain headed this way
metaphorically oh
[Music]
man
hi hi
I have a boyfriend yes we're all fully
aware
[Music]
I want to tell people
it's hard to find the right time
your finger feels so nice how'd you get
to know everyone uh
well um
I want you to come out when and how
[Music]
and how
is the worst person to have a crush on
well if you're trying to actually fight
with him my mum's been moaning at me to
get a haircut it has a coupon
if this doesn't work out then I lose my
best friend in the whole world
uh
and I love you
that's not me asking you to say it back
or anything yeah
does Charlie know you don't want to come
out I do want to come out
is everyone ready for Paris
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm jealous of you and Megan's almost
you talk about your feelings
I can make sure that Nick doesn't have
to deal with what I did I can protect
him
everything's going to be perfect
oh my god do you think anyone wanted us
oh my God
I've liked him for so
like him back
if you make mistakes sometimes you're a
good person who deserves love
they are gonna be a handful today
[Music]
you don't have to understand your
feelings completely you don't have to
always feed everything out you can just
feel
taking Charlie
oh you're being gay
good job carry on
[Music]
they broke your arm
nice the hospitals make me so nervous
they smell funny and they're ghosts
everywhere
no rest for the weary huh I don't have
time for a rest I've got a trial coming
up they could have killed you Mickey I
didn't ask for this it was just doing my
job it's got to be another way to do
your job save
[Applause]
a lot of things with conventional that's
not one of them
[Music]
do not turn this trial into a circus
holler Andy everything's gonna be okay
don't let yourselves be fooled see
through Mr holler's parlor tricks to the
truth
is everything okay yeah yeah I'm sure
everything's gonna be fine
if you sacrifice too much for this job
you'll end up alone it's a terrible
Hollywood cliche
you are Mickey holler and you win cases
that's what you do no matter who you're
just diverted
we have your honor
[Music]
when I was little
I used to dream about fire
is an element that requires friction
fuel and oxygen
it would have been flames
[Music]
Alice is my granddaughter and she will
be living with us from now on
some people in this town don't like the
idea of women running a farm
they don't like that we keep to
ourselves and that we're different
what the hell
of it
every day is a chance to start
up Alice deserves that
and we do too
you really think that a refuge full of
dramatized people is the best place for
her she's lost her whole family
no she hasn't
[Music]
there's things you need to know
thank you
are you part of it a part of what
ever can you tell me oh Crush
are we still gonna run away
you lied to us
[Music]
I promised I'd keep her safe
but out there we can't protect her be
careful he can be alive
[Music]
Alice needs to understand that what
really happened
[Music]
how could you
you need to fix this journey there's
plenty of time to tell her the rest
[Music]
do you think the Lakers can win another
title you bet any advice for your
opponents
better watch out
[Music]
magic pack baby
basketball is the sport of the decade
you got the kids on the team now the bus
Empire's taken off
we brought home to go but one ring Ain't
Gonna Keep Us in that room
gotta keep winning
[Music]
look Herman
you know why nobody repeats
because the guys that you beat along the
way I spent all that time figuring out
new ways to break you down
they're [__] girls
they're [__] fans
[Applause]
[Music]
with this pain to win
things change
I am in charge not Magic
a real Coach doesn't need to prove it
Paul
can we comment on Magic's new contract
a basketball team is like a family you
pick out any one member others would
wonder whether or not they belong
did you say your head coach interim
coach or
look good in that chair probably
something huh a woman owner
you could bring him home 100 trophies
you're never gonna be his favorite son
they're in the dynasty
we're the flash in the pan
and that's all we're ever gonna be
until we beat the goddamn Celtics [__]
Boston
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody's a [__] hero in their
driveway
put them on in the bright lights
most of them praying that the ball don't
come to them
one guy's praying that it does
[Music]
it's opening night and a big star drops
dead on stage oh my God my leading man
is dead is this really happening well
you know who are we without a homicide
the Killer is someone in this room my
show is hanging on by a thread here
finding this killer is the only way
you'll have a show
want to make a podcast with me
God this is corny
murder yeah murder him look at this cast
they're all killers but who would want
to kill Ben maybe it was Loretta please
please don't give up on me I'm not good
the table reads
in the rocks
I say give her the booty maybe it was
Kimber The Tick Tock addicted Starlet
does she do it as part of an internet
meme
why are you saying it like that
I think I got a lead
Potter you're investigating with this
guy so Oliver and Charles what do you
talk about murder ously
how to connect Bluetooth and talk about
that a lot we're on to something here
but I need you to draw attention to
yourself that's no biggie that's a
smallie it's a very small thing because
that because it's a
[Music]
your show is a death trap today alone I
almost died three times
[Music]
oh my God I was trapped yours went by do
I have a beard is SNL still on you were
gone for 20 minutes
theater is all about choices
what you share and what you hide it's a
clue
those choices change everything
get her talking I can just girl talk can
you yeah you guys okay out here hey Mama
yeah we're like uh yes they work and
slay over here like yeah
oh I don't think so
at least you had the consideration to
keep the body out of the building this
time you always know just what to say
I am an investigator with the U.S
attorney's Office you lie you heard
people you go down you ever prosecute
company as big as Purdue farmer
all of human behavior is essentially
comprised of two things
run from pain
run toward pleasure pain pleasure pain
pleasure if we place ourselves right
there between pain and pleasure we will
never have to worry about money again
pain is no longer something we have to
tolerate we have an answer something
legally prescribed be killing so many
people tell me what words you associate
with oxycodone oxy what
[Applause]
oxycoffins excuse me don't put that in
the notes we are under investigation
[Music]
the cotton you like horror movies
you will be convincing doctors to take
pain seriously
Aussie cotton is the one to start with
and the one to stay with the more you
prescribe Memorial health it is now the
number one opioid in the country
this drug is permeating every part of
our community
you're the cutest little Oxycontin
kitten we've seen on a minute
[Music]
if it's working which it is we can
increase the dose let's kick you up to
40 milligrams it doesn't just kill
people it destroys the family
and friends you're a drug dealer with a
ponytail you bought that car with the
death of a 16 year old girl
they are doing the exact same thing as
every crack dealer in America
that they are getting rewarded for it
they know they are killing people
Richard Sackler hello you were
you did a good job making all that money
sir
thank you
if you don't get out of my way I'll run
you over with my car and crush your
skull
[Music]
then you'll give me Oxycontin to make it
right
[Music]
now would you stop playing Pupa shot
he's not an arcade game for sake wait is
his voice just gonna be like that from
now on yeah but nobody's gonna notice
[Music]
the last few months have been a [__]
repairing the ship on weekends slogging
through that boring ass office job from
now on I'm the boss baby well not the
boss baby but I am your boss baby damn
it now I want a bottle of milk
good exercise in the daytime a big part
of the mission is US fitting in on Earth
everyone looked like a perfect non-weird
family why do you have to be like this
the wall could be frozen over in two
months everyone will die Jesse will save
us all four hi there little friend did
you get lost what's your name my name is
know how we've been trying to find
something that will complete us as a
family it's the theme of the Season make
us a dino song
drop that beat one two a one two three
four
[Music]
as the pupa specialist let me say he's
fine wait where is he
goggly when he sleeps
the solar opposites are going on a road
trip
okay this time daddy got us a regular
bus with almost no bombs baby yeah baby
Terry you're human oh my gosh do you
have a butthole I don't know you tell me
I shot a ton of CEOs 12 covers the snake
thing has got to be the craziest origin
story I've ever heard honestly it was
boring compared to what came next
started off in coastal Florida I got
thriving here we're prepared to purchase
our entire crop what do you say
[Applause]
we're in business no vaccies
second my business got even a tiny bit
of success people showed up trying to
take it I want to talk to you about a
proposition
what happens if I say no
come on what the hell did you feed
engager well the thing about Buttercup
don't name him and definitely not
buttercup
This creepy Swamp family they screwed me
over we split the prophets 80 20.
Vanessa and Camille are counting on me
I'd rather keep it above board who are
you I'm with the state of Florida we're
shutting you down don't worry guys it
will keep getting paid and Margarita
Monday is still on you can't promise
them that I already Juiced the lives
Craig
[Music]
my farm the eye on shut up I promise
it's a plan it won't be pretty let's go
suit up
Dolores you have to wear underwear in
the common areas
it's a common area and I'm naked there
your room makes no sense
we are building a business here no
crimes no scams it's time we escalate
this situation sometimes in business
people get hurt
what was that wow that was crazy do you
think I might be repressing some anger
yes Jillian I do think so
[Music]
war is inevitable one Must Destroy
in order to create
we are no Jedi
[Music]
I started hearing whispers
of thrawn's return as heir to the Empire
what happens when we find thrawn
power
such as you've never dreamed
[Music]
[Applause]
I've spent most of my life fighting a
war
that's why I'm trying to convince you to
help me prevent another one
you and I both know who could help you
with this
she's still just as stubborn as ever
I bet your master found you difficult at
times Anakin never got to finish my
training I walked away from him just
like I walked away from Sabine you've
never made things easy for me
master
as a Jedi sometimes you have to make the
decision no one else can
but I'm counting on you to see this
through
nice haircut
sometimes we have to do what's right
regardless of our personal feelings
if we don't stop thrawn everything will
be in vain
[Music]
Lincoln spoke highly of you
I'm not here to discuss my past
we have a lot of work to do once a rebel
always a rebel
[Music]
it has been 121 days since the aliens
invaded our world
we have suffered
we have sacrificed
lives
loved ones
connection it's the only chance we'll
have to learn what they want
how to stop them
[Music]
my fellow Global Citizens
look up
this is our enemy together we will win
this war
aliens somehow connected us
this is our last chance for survival
it sounds mental
The Whole World's mental right
[Music]
you hold this family together they
adapted wheeler death
what if you could save everybody
[Music]
if you want to win a war
a fight back
[Music]
right here
are you sure you want to do this
[Music]
well
babe power
I found everything in this world has to
offer
[Applause]
free yourselves paint to the Seas
bye treasure
is yours to find
so what do you say
are you with me
[Music]
mutiny
why would anyone want to be a pirate
this is the best thing there is
I mean you're back
salty Seer
loyal crew by your side
[Music]
it's ready what is it or Jolly Roger we
are the straw hat crew
[Music]
we're heading up to the Grand line
treacherous stretch of ocean with bigger
islands
anchor Pirates
that's where we're gonna find the one
piece
we've been making enemies everywhere we
go
they are hunting you
[Music]
guys save your ass well I saved euros
you'll have to excuse them they're
idiots oh
[Music]
it's cool our crew
can handle anything
I'll tell you the kindness of killing
you all together
you're my captain from now until the end
[Music]
I'm gonna kick your ass cause no one
messes with my friends
what's so special about you
[Music]
I'm Monkey D loopy
and I'm gonna be king of the Pirates
I didn't know there were so many Pirates
it's terrible I know right
where's my face
[Music]
foreign